hi I'm Nicolas be with recent TV and
today we're talking to Ryan grim the
author of the excellent new book this is
your country on drugs the secret history
of getting high in America Ryan what is
the ten-second version of your book 10
second version Americans have always
gotten high
we have always we always will get high
and we will always try to stop other
people from getting high right that's
probably the N and there will be many
tears in the process right what in doing
the research for the book what was the
most surprised I'm II NAT which is
fascinating because you come from a
starting point that most people want to
ignore which is that is the long history
of intoxication in these United States
as well as the rest of the world what
was the most surprising fact that came
out of your research that you had no
idea of in terms of a secret history of
getting high yeah just the fact that our
history is so layered and textured and
and deep was probably the most
surprising thing the the greatest
revelation to me was when I started
studying the temperance movement in the
19th century which succeeded to a large
degree in reducing drinking by a
significant amount but at the same time
using opium and poor sophistic sand
other things you can show that just as
drinking was going down opium use is
coming back is coming up and then opium
use ends up leading to this just
cornucopia of pharmaceutical like utopia
for drug users in the 1890s which of
course you know collapses into a
dystopia and then they end up banning
everything but so in a you know in a
very real way it was this temperance
movement that ushered this whole thing
in right and now that was the mo that
was the most surprising thing to me just
the connection between the two
contradictory parts of our tea here here
is a question I mean American culture in
virtually across every dimension is
manichaean I mean everything is black
and white or wheat we tend to extremes
is there hope for a system of
responsible drug use or intok
- continues in America or is it always
going to be on the one hand you have
teetotalers and on the other hand you
have addicts or wets and drys I mean do
we have a workable history of moderate
drug use
I think marijuana will be will be the
the thing that might break our our our
history of this black and white wets and
dry thing because throughout the history
a drug comes in we embrace it there's no
stigma attached to it it's something
that medicine or God has provided to us
it's fine then overnight it becomes not
fine it becomes criminal than something
new pops in and then the other drug safe
it was cocaine in the 1890s it
disappears and then when it reappears in
the 70s we go through the whole cycle
again but nowhere where for instance
cocaine in the 70s it was chic it was
non-addictive it had no known side
effects etc and then five years later
it's the beginning of a new panic right
you had people testifying before counter
like medical researchers testifying
before Congress in the early eighties
late 70s that there was no nothing wrong
with it like go go for it use it
Carter's drug czar said hey we might
even think about legalizing this and so
they had forgotten what had happened in
the 1890s but it's different with pot
since the sixties it's been part of our
consciousness despite all the efforts to
get rid of it so at this point you know
anybody that is in their 60s or below
has an experience with with marijuana
either they've used it or they know
somebody who's used it and they know
that the sky hasn't fallen as a result
of it and as as that continues you'll
have a jet you'll have an everyone will
what will have a more mature like you
know great shade of gray type of
relationship with it do you think we're
also at a point where for the first time
since these surveys have been taken a
majority of Americans say they're in
favor of legalizing marijuana medical
marijuana is in over a dozen states
places like California are actually
talking about legalizing marijuana
they've already legalized and had a
running feud with the federal government
is marijuana likely to be legalized
within the next five years it might it
might happen there are a couple of
interesting things going on in in the
late 70s which was the the peak of
marijuana use in America you still only
had twenty thirty percent favoring
legalization you had more people smoking
it than people who were in favor of
making it illegal to smoke it but now
you have more people who favored
legalizing it then actually smoked it
the most interesting thing to me is is a
as a couple of surveys that were done
about people's attitudes toward
legalizing medical marijuana they asked
a two-tier poll they said do you support
legalizing medical marijuana and people
overwhelmingly in in the states where
this was done said yes I support it then
they said do a majority of people in
your state support legalizing medical
marijuana and only some twenty to thirty
percent said yes so everybody thought
that they were the enlightened one and
their neighbors are these you know
reactionary groups who you know just
want to like you know rip up their pot
plants from their backyard now what
happens is that when it actually gets
legalized in say California medical
marijuana gets legalized
when they when they pull again it pulls
ten twenty points higher than it
actually got in in the voting booth
people people realize oh I'm not the
only enlightened one here or they
realize this isn't so bad so once people
realize that they're not alone in their
kind of libertarian sensibility towards
marijuana then people start talking
about it and then it just steamrolled
because there's no legitimate argument
against it
the modern drug war with that phrase and
whatnot dates back to Richard Nixon he
was terrible on drugs Jimmy Carter not
so bad George Ford not so bad Reagan not
good first Bush not good Clinton not
good second Bush not good
Obama is he gonna be good or bad it'll
depend on the rest of his agenda and
that's one of the things I read about in
the book that drug policy is like the
stepchild of government policy and it is
always the last thing that is taken into
account whether you're talking about
going to war in
Stan or Nicaragua or passing a trade
deal with with Mexico that doesn't
matter the the drugs are secondary
so if Obama can get to say health care
passed and he really gets rolling and
he's got a lot of political capital then
he's then he's gonna be progressive he's
gonna he's gonna he's gonna push forward
on the you know exchange so he's already
been better on than anybody else on
medical marijuana just by not arresting
people so it will depend on how much
capital he's got to spend on it I so in
other words it's looking pretty bad for
water let's talk a little bit how did
you get interested in this topic yeah it
was uh it was a total accident in around
2001 I realized that I hadn't seen LSD
in several years or in in several months
and and I started I started looking and
so I wrote a story about it in 2004
about how there was no acid left got
more emails on that story than any I've
ever written before or since nobody said
they had it and it indicated me that
there was there was a password mark is
waiting to be served but it took a few
years off he made a lot of money on acid
exactly I'm back with the book what do
you think is the do we have a drug
problem in America or do we have a drug
prohibition problem in America there
isn't a drug problem in the sense that
it hurts our GDP or or it causes
unemployment or or it has any other you
know impact on the structure of our of
our economy although there are people
who have substance abuse elute Lee and
and almost everyone knows somebody who
has a substance abuse problem but our
country still still goes on it's not
it's not a it's not a crisis for the
country it's a crisis for that family
and it's a crisis for that person now
where we do have a structural threat to
the country is with what you say with
prohibition that the the spending you
know forty billion dollars on just on
prison costs the cost to the economy of
people who are less employable because
of drug charges or the cost of
enforcement itself you know where cops
are out chasing you know baggies instead
of actual actual crime there it has a it
has a real possibility of undermining
the structure of the of the economy and
of the society so I think that's why
you're probably you're most likely to
see a change to Prohibition because I
see it as kind of a prohibition it's
kind of a luxury of good times you know
it's all fun and games to lock everybody
up when you have budget surpluses and
and when the global financial system
isn't collapsing well I want to thank
you for joining us today at Reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie we've been talking to
Ryan Graham the author of the excellent
new book this is your country on drugs
the secret history of getting high in
America